I was reading a study the other day on
marital stability.
Gottman has done some really good
analysis of couples behavior.
He has set up a lab that's basically a
bed and breakfast and he brings couples
in there for a weekend and he had wires
the mop physiologically and monitors
their reactivity and so what is he can
predict whether a couple's going to
divorce with 95,
94 percent accuracy.
It's like impressive.
So what is he found?
He found two categories of.
He's.
He's identified two phenomena that are
very much worth knowing.
The first is that the couples who are
going to get divorced and they come into
the bed and breakfast and they speak
with each other quite commonly,
but it's more walking on eggs calm and
while they're speaking with each other,
normally their physiology is like
they're very aroused and so.
So they're sort of aroused like someone
who's facing a predator.
So you might think about not unhappy,
couple as Predator and prey to each
other.
And so the words are there mostly to
stop predatory activity,
not to actually communicate anything.
It's just to keep the surface calm.
So then you might think,
well,
what's under the surface and what it's
under the surface.
So Freud would say it's what's under the
surface is unconscious and,
but you can say,
well,
what's under the surface is one of these
hierarchies and it's all banged up and
twisted and,
and not in reasonable shape.
And so people don't want to open the
door to that.
So.
But they do.
And this is a Freudian slip.
So let's say this goes to the second
part of the Gottman's observations.
So
the woman goes over to the window and
she says,
oh look,
there's a cardinal outside,
you know,
cardinals,
that bright red bird,
that kind of cool looking,
you know,
it's kind of a trivial thing in some
sense,
but by the same token,
it's like it's a little positive thing
and you know,
20 of them in a day's good thing.
Okay?
So then the,
uh,
the partner,
the husband in this example has a two by
two matrix of choices.
One is,
who the hell cares about your stupid
bird?
Okay,
so that's one.
The second one is then you go over and
look at the bird,
right?
And then the third one is you don't make
the contempt noise but you act it out
and the fourth one is you go over there
like a civilized human being and you
know,
and that you're interacting with someone
that you care for and you take a look at
the damn bird and you're happy about it
and it.
And that's as truthful and real as you
can manage.
Okay,
so the option,
that's a Freudian slip,
right?
Because what it says,
there's a whole monster underneath that
and the monster,
all the disorganization in this entire
structure.
It's like the might be.
We have been tormenting each other about
various things for the last 10 years and
none of them are resolved and I'm not
very happy about you for so many
reasons.
I can't even remember all of them and I
can't enumerate them right now because
that would take forever and maybe we
would have a huge fight.
But by the same token,
I'm not going to come over there and
make you happy with your stupid bird and
I'm going to indicate that suddenly so
you can't call me a son of a bitch
because I've just sighing and that's
what I'll say if you do ask me,
but I'm going to load all that up and
I'm going to deliver it to you.
And what's going to happen to you is
because you're smart,
is your heart rate's going to go way up,
like you're being attacked.
And the reason for that is you are.
So what the good couples do,
the couples that you know will stay
together is they respond to each other's
bids.
He calls them bids.
And so if one person wants to share some
little trivial daily positive thing with
the other,
you know,
isn't carrying around a bloody cartload
of resentment and is able to respond to
that in a positive way.
And that way the general interactions
between the couples stay positive.
But that's also because they've worked
this out.
Now,
you know it's got to be because they
work it out because the couples who are
physiologically reactive to each other,
they're communicating,
but there's all sorts of horror
underneath the surface and we're trying
to figure out,
well,
what is it that's underneath the
surface?
What's the structure of the unconscious?
Well,
that's the structure of the unconscious
and it's either well structured and
functional and mutually agreed upon and
as explicit as possible,
or it's this constantly.